HIS OBEDIENCE MASK.
HE GRABBED IT AND WALKED AWAY.
HERE IS FOX NEWS POLITICAL
ANALYST.
WHAT IS -- I THINK ALL OF US WHO
ARE OVER THE AGE OF 13
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HUMAN BEINGS
THAT MAKE TERRIBLE MISTAKES
OFTEN.
WHAT IS SO INFURIATING IS THEIR
UNWILLINGNESS TO SAKE I'M SORRY,
WE SCREWED UP, HERE'S WHERE WE
WRONG.
JUST ADMIT PUBLICLY AND WITH
SINCERITY WHAT THE REST OF US
ARE SEEING.
BY WHAT THEY DO THAT?
>> IT HAS BEEN A REFUSAL TO DO
THAT SINCE THIS DEBACLE FIRST
BEGAN TO UNFOLD.
I THINK CHARACTERIZING THIS
PRESIDENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RESPONSE TO IT
BECAUSE, THERE WERE HEROIC
THINGS DONE BY THE MILITARY AND
I THINK AS WELL BY DIPLOMATS
WORKING ON DISK TO TRY TO GET AS
MANY PEOPLE OUT AS THEY COULD.
BUT THEY WEREN'T RESPONDING TO
AN EMERGENCY OF THE PREOWNED
CREATION.
THERE IS NOT A MILITARY
STRATEGIST I KNOW OF OUR PLANET
THAT IS NOT THINK THAT THIS
WHOLE EVACUATION WAS SERIOUSLY
UNDER PLANT, UNDERMANNED, AND
POORLY THOUGHT OUT AND BRUSHED.
SO CLEARLY, THE COURT WAS DEAD.
AND THAT IS BIDEN'S DOING.
BIDEN WANTED OUT.
HE WANTED OUT IN A HURRY.
AND HE GOT THAT MILITARY OUT OF
THERE.
WHICH SEEMS TO BE HIS CHIEF
OBJECTIVE.
SUPPOSE HE CAME OUT TODAY AND
SAID, LOOK, IT WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION TO GET OUT.
BUT WE DID NOT EXECUTE IT WELL
AND I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
THESE ARE MY DECISIONS.
I REGRET THEM DEEPLY.
I BULGES FOR THEM.
I'M DEEPLY REGRETFUL OF THE LOSS
OF LIFE THIS MADE INTERPRET AND
IF WE HAVE TO SEND TROOPS TO GET
OUR PEOPLE OUT, WE WILL IN THE
TALIBAN OUGHT TO KNOW THAT.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS I'M
RESPONSIBLE.
I'M SORRY.
WE ARE GOING TO DO BETTER.
MY GUESS IS AND YOU DON'T SEE
THIS IN MODERN POLITICS, BUT MY
GUESS IS THE PUBLIC WOULD BE
MUCH MORE FORGIVING OF HIM THEN
THEY ARE LIKELY TO BE NOW.
>> Tucker: I MEAN THIS.
I TRULY MEAN TO.
>> I WOULD BE GRATEFUL TO HEAR
THAT FROM HIM OR ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE FOR THEM TO
TELL US THAT WHAT WE ARE SEEING
ON TELEVISION IS NOT A DISASTER,
THAT EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
IT IS A MASSIVE SUCCESS.
YOU WONDER, HOW LONG CAN THEY
KEEP SAYING THAT?
WHAT IS THE PLAN HERE?
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA?
>> WELL, I THINK POLITICAL
TERMS, TUCKER, WHAT I SUSPECTED
IS THIS IS NEVER TO RALLY THAT
FATEFUL.
THE PEOPLE SOMETHING TO SAY AND
YOU HEARD THE WORDS OF MATTHEW
DOUBT THERE, IT IS ALMOST BEYOND
COMPREHENSION.
THAT THIS IS A SUCCESS BEYOND
WHAT ANYONE IMAGINES.
BIDEN WITH THINK THAT AS WELL.
YOU SEE PIECES OF THAT INSERTION
WE GET WHERE PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO STICK UP FOR THE TEMPLATE BUT
THAT FOUR I THINK BY AND LARGE
ACROSS THE NEWS MEDIA HAS BEEN
ALMOST UNANIMOUS CONDEMNATION OF
THIS AS A FAILURE.
IT IS PRETTY WELL SET NOW.
I THINK IN THAT MONTHS OF
JOURNALISTS WHO ARE COVERING
WASHINGTON, COVERING THE
PENTAGON, COVERING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, COVERING THE WHITE
HOUSE, THAT THIS HAS BEEN AN
EMPTY.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY TO
OVERTURN, AND I THINK THE PUBLIC
HAVING SEEN WEEKS OF THIS WILL
PROBABLY REACH THE SAME
JUDGMENT, WHETHER THEY ARE
WILLING TO FORGIVE BIDEN OR NOT